vuelven a sonar las alarmas por el cobre
19 en europa ya que según la o ms es el
único continente del mundo en el que
están aumentando las muertes por el
virus con un incremento del 5 por ciento
en la última semana en alemania con la
tasa de incidencia y la ocupación de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos al alza
el gobierno de angela merkel advirtió de
la gravedad de la situación
la situación actual de la pandemia es
dramática no puedo decirlo de otra
manera la cuarta ola golpeó a nuestro
país con toda su fuerza y aunque no hay
más fundamento legal para la situación
de emergencia nacional pandémica no
tengo ninguna duda que nos encontramos
en medio de tal situación de emergencia
en francia han optado por pedir a las
empresas que impulsen el teletrabajo y a
pesar de mostrarse optimista el
ejecutivo galo no descarta aplicar
medidas si es necesario
yo sigo siendo cautelosamente optimista
repito cautelosamente optimista los
datos y los modelos que tenemos del
instituto pasteur muestran que con el
nivel actual de vacunación probablemente
tenemos las herramientas para limitar el
impacto de la quinta ola
mientras que en austria siguen
registrando récord de casos a pesar de
la imposición del confinamiento para los
no vacunados desde el lunes una polémica
medida que se está debatiendo en toda
europa por lo que denuncian es una
restricción de libertades y para algunos
su cuestionada efectividad
no se puede diferenciar a las personas
de esa manera crear dos clases sociales
creo deberíamos volver a un cierre total
y que eso no es factible
si la situación no mejora ya o ms ya ha
advertido que el continente podría
llegar a sumar 500.000 muertes más por
el virus hasta febrero